And I'd prefer number 2. Any of these could be correct, especially depending on
how close you live to a beach and how nice the weather is today, but I'm going
to suggest that we do number 2. And the reason that we do number 2, rather than,
refining next day, is I like to procrastinate. The grungy work of dealing with
all the complexity of real months. Let's put that off till later. The advantage
of doing 2 first is we'll have a lot of confidence we're on the right track if
this works. We'll be very close. We'll be getting approximate answers. We'll see
that we're on the right track. And then, we can figure out those details but we
won't need to change this code later. So, let's go ahead and see if we can write
days between dates using the next day procedure. We won't get exact answers that
are correct here because our next day procedure is not quite correct.